[Musique]
ce matin la traque des fugitifs connu
sous le nom des rues du diable s'est
achevée dans un affrontement violent
avec la police le pronostic vital est
fortement engagée avec le sens sur un
million de survie
y a pas de justice dans ce monde de
merde je suis moi jusqu'ici vaine que
nous mettre le danger c'est pas nous me
d'étriller libéré friands
c'est vraiment le jour des normes
tu veux dire quelque chose j'ai envie de
faire la paix
c'est chez moi ici
c'est un clown qui dansent pour
expliquer au nom de l'humanité
tu va être mangé
[Applaudissements]
ici c'est mon usine n a qu à vivre
maintenant c'est toi nos produits
j'adore
salut à toi d'américains je t'ai manqué
[Musique]
toi
oui ça a pris
tu
à
c'est bizarre qui vivent seules
son pâté curité c'est sûr si on part sur
l'argent camilla est morte ya quelqu'un
d'autre dans la maison par pitié ne
descendez pas c'est quoi ça l'assise
entame arrêter de parler et de marché
elle m'a demandé pourquoi dieu le
punisse et
tamara les noms de la demi volée du
droit partez donc il est encore tôt
tamara
la maroc
je n'ai jamais vu une possession aussi
puissante délivre nous du mal un des
livres nous devons attendre le début et
au ya quelqu'un mon dieu qu'il n'est pas
seul
ils sont des centaines
attends
[Applaudissements]
la surface à ce témoin camara
tenez vous prêts car le jour qui
approche est le jour de la révolution
quand le petit pas que c'est pas bien
où peut bien venu discussions le parking
de rattrapage
j'ai pas mal de choses à vous dire vous
allez me parler du prochain 11 septembre
et ce type là moïse shabazz un loup
solitaire classique ils sont quatre une
meute de loups solitaires salle berlioz
le tout puissant nous ordonne de
transmettre notre savoir alarme chez
vous voir la domination accidentelle de
la race blanche être renversé cool vous
pourrez lui faire franchir la ligne
rouge est bien sûr on lui donne
réellement une fausse bombe il en fera
bon usage qui tient le prochain
la mission est de changer la vie des
pauvres gens sans aucune harmattan
offrons un défaut les armes automatiques
peut-être que votre arme et aurait
besoin d'un nom nous ne croyons pas aux
armes et si besoin on appellera les
dinosaures
nous croyons ils viendront nous aider
mais j'ai fait une erreur je crois qu'il
ya un peu fou je le sens pas du tout
écoutez je suis simplement un type comme
ça
parlant à un autre type essayant d'en
mettre un troisième épisode est en train
de et si c'était moi qui étais en train
de les avoir
qui est-ce qui voudraient m'avoir qu'est
ce qu'on fait
vous pouvez nous payer 50 mille dollars
je peux vous montrer quelqu'un qui vend
des ak 47
il nous a signalé nous comme étant une
menace
[Musique]
c'est un moyen pour lui de sa sortie son
moyen de s'en sortir c'est d'aller en
prison
[Musique]
ah ah
ce n'est qu'une sirène qu'ils utilisent
pour appeler les dinosaures
[Musique]
cet état d'urgence et sans fondement cj
miles et état d'urgence et que six
fruits et on ne peut pas en prendre le
contrôle si on dit qu'il n'existe pas
arrêter cet état d'urgence je dois
déclarer l'état d'urgence au gîte les
régions que si vous le dites le
lentement et en mettant les éléments
contradictoires d'un côté
bon alors je crois qu'on est en état
d'urgence nucléaire bien jouer
mademoiselle
[Musique]
monsieur hamilton tu aimes ce que tu
vois
heures
pourquoi est ce que quelqu'un voudrait
que tu ne sois plus en vite est-ce que
tu pars code administratif 8,4 de 2,7
confirmé cible neutraliser
je sais que tu es attaché à 20 moi je
dis qu'elle peut nous compromettre non
pas elle cette fille c'est la meilleure
c'est moi qui les recruter et former
elle parle un petit bleu vert qui
parasite et je te le promets que tu vas
bientôt retiré jeune fille mais
l'administration va être
particulièrement prudent dorénavant tu
as fait quelque chose de mal
ils ne m'auraient pas envoyer autrement
[Musique]
qui est responsable
la compagnie avait rien à voir là dedans
tu crois pas à ça indique n'arrête pas
d'enfreindre le protocole je t'ai
demandé en mariage et a disparu sans
même me donner d'explications
elle a toujours été la préférée de doc
elle représente un réel danger pour
l'accompagnement tu veux avoir un
morceau de cette fille
dix huit ça peut être une dans un doigt
peu importe
t'avais prévenu je serais peut-être pas
capable de protéger une deuxième fois
tu dois annuler l'ordre d'exécution tu
sais que je peux pas faire ça c'est les
affaires
c'est un beau matin pour saab
[Musique]
mettez les gardes de sécurité ma famille
en alerte
[Musique]
nous on s'occupe des ennemis du reich
des enfants juifs une fois qu'ils
arrivent ici benjamin et fait passer
clandestinement en espagne par les
montagnes là bas ils sont en sécurité
mes hommes et moi seront postés à lescun
pour faire en sorte qu'aucun français ou
juifs en fuite
le traverse les montagnes vers l'espagne
déjà on voit ce qu'il veut voir son bien
trop paresseux pour chercher autre chose
quand on voit un homme voire avant midi
pense que c'est un ivrogne pas les
bookies où on voit une vieille ferme
noir on pense que tu ne peuvent pas une
simple
regards sont les bras ap la commission
on pense que c'est un coursier par aof
si à un moment donné je me retrouve face
à eux je n'en mènerait au moins avec moi
[Musique]
on
l'air a été fabuleux chez même plus des
oies c'est des nuages vous vous faites
comment avec les enfants on n'a pas le
temps avec nous dit on voyage plus tôt
la seconde table à jeddah le borrigo
l'est plus tout jeunes vous deux qu'est
ce que vous attendez
mais elle veut pas dans le fond c'est ça
qui s'occupe de tout de sa pilule et
tout ça sur un cours de cette petite
pilule
[Musique]
quoi
j'ai grossi grossi cher était magnifique
mais c'est quoi ces messages sont
énormes
oui il ya une grosse heure là une tumeur
mais je comprends c'est un bébé un bébé
cancer
concours le plus plus faire ça écoute
claire du m en occuper surtout seul
votre faim n'a pas pu vous accompagner
elle travaille meiway toi ouais je
présente be blood
bonjour bible salaire au bonjour quel
salaire j'ai mangé du camembert et après
pour faire passer le goût du camembert
j'ai pris du vin tu les mamans je veux
du fromage prend du fromage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du vol et des vols
[Musique]
c'est moi qui vais la laisser madame les
hommes allaient apprendre une prothèse
d'accord qui est relié aux mamelons il
avait joué une psychologue
[Musique]
l'année aura forcément
on voit tout ce qu'aucune alain denis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ats
cette année
[Musique]
bon ça
mais ce toit
[Musique]
break prépare tes affaires on doit
changer de corps oui
il était à ma recherche parce que je
suis une fille ouais
je suis la dernière fille au monde
et le tchad ouais et venait de naître
quand tout est arrivé
il faudra que tu la protèges on
keira vous rappelle sans toi
messi
on verra sur l'autre
je connais personne à part toi ouais moi
quand le reste du monde ça me plaît oui
moi aussi aller voir kaka ya même délit
regarde ça on peut rester ici
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est bon
dopés par leur a souvent de moi d'accord
tu lui diras que j'aurais voulu la voir
grandir
lloris qui se passe
[Musique]
sortez de là
ce matin
ouais
fin de l'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]